yesterday i got an email from jimmy
kimmel in the subject is he really has a
way with words and it's one of ronnie's
tweets from the day and it says uh yeah
it's titty tuesday
it said
yeah
so i said to jason i go what's titty
tuesday really mean and the way i
understood it was
he like the call of the wild he screams
out early in the morning titty tuesday
and then what i thought was happening is
people would send them pictures of girls
titties
right and then you know people could see
them and enjoy them instead what i what
i learned is happening he puts out titty
tuesday
and people are sending them titty girl
titty pictures but
he doesn't share them he just he
acquires them for himself he's
accumulating
teddy girl pictures yeah
what are you talking about dude i put
him out
not according to gary and jason they
don't see
one highlight of the week once a week
usually not a titty shot and then like
yesterday you brought titty tuesday and
all these people are sending you shots
of of course you'll see i just retweet i
favor them that's it
yeah
how do we see them
when you favor something it goes up you
see it
no favor it's favor
favor whatever
old bag dude you're putting out the call
of the wild for titty tuesday and you're
not sharing the titty
i'm sure oh they come all right but not
to anyone else but you it's pervy no
[ __ ]
okay
jason do i have it wouldn't you have to
retweet
jason to send it out yeah of course he
puts out the highlight of the week but
that seems to be once a week but on
titty tuesday now wait a minute jason
jason yeah
this guy puts up [ __ ] he puts up
pictures
thunk two thunk three titties
okay how old are you again
i i get uh i just favored or favorited
all of them
so you do see him but you understand
when you favorite something it doesn't
tweet it out it just saves it to a list
that you can look and i guess if
somebody went to your specific profile
yeah if i go no if it goes it goes on my
page
what
you're not retweeting it you don't even
know what you're doing i'm not
retweeting it i don't want to retweet it
what was the other jason when all of a
sudden two days it's like you know when
sometimes thanksgiving and like uh purim
fall on the same day you know what i
mean like what was it it was titty
friday and sometimes but also song
friday it was the first according to
ronnie yeah yeah on friday and a titty
friday so how can you have titty friday
and thung friday
like how does that happen oh you could
have him on this i thought it was titty
tuesday well sometimes you gotta mix it
up dude yeah
but ronnie's consistent he's got on
mondays it's good monday morning with
his last name uh replaced for monday
titty tuesday to you with a whole bunch
of o's in every word
happy hump days on wednesdays song
thursdays and then no alliteration on
fridays it's just friday's anything
anything over yeah
i got another list it's rusty trombone
tuesday whip out your wanker wednesday
prick trust thursday uh i've got a lot
here for friday furry box friday flash
your tits friday felt terrain is friday
fellatio friday